i'm going to tell you a true story but
instead of the name of the protagonist
i'm going to make you think about your
favorite artist think about your
favorite musician and think about your
favorite song by that musician think
about them bringing that song from
nothing to something into your ears and
bringing you so much joy now think about
your favorite musician getting sued and
that lawyer saying i represent this
group i think you heard their song and
then you wrote your song you violated
their copyright and imagine you're a
musician saying no that's not true i
don't think i've ever heard that song
but even if i did i certainly wasn't
thinking about them when i made my song
imagine the case going to trial and a
judge saying you know i think i believe
you musician i don't think you
consciously copied that group but what i
think did happen is you subconsciously
copied them
you violated the copyright and you have
to pay them a lot of money
think about whether that's fair
think about whether that's just
now this actually happened to george
harrison the league guitarist of the
beatles and the group was the chiffons
who has had a song
he's so fine oh so fine and george
harrison had a song my sweet lord oh
sweet lord but what neither george
harrison nor the chiffons nor the judge
really nor anybody else had considered
is maybe since the beginning of time the
number of melodies is remarkably finite
maybe there are only so many melodies in
this world and the chiffons when they
picked their melody plucked it from that
already existing finite melodic dataset
and george harrison happened to have
plucked the same melody from that same
finite melodic data set
this is a different way of thinking
about music in a way that judges and
lawyers haven't thought about nor have
musicians because when those groups have
thought about musicians they think about
them drawing from their own creative
offspring bringing from nothing
something into the world they have a
blank page upon which they can put their
creativity that's actually not true as
george harrison realized you have to
avoid every song that's ever been
written because if you don't avoid those
songs you get sued if you're lucky you
pluck one of those already existing
melodies that hasn't been taken if
you're unlucky you pluck a melody that's
already been taken whether you've heard
that song or not maybe you've never
heard it before now if that happens if
you're lucky you have a co-songwriter
somebody else says you know that new
song sounds a lot like that old song you
say oh gosh thank goodness and you
change it before it goes out the door
now if you're unlucky you don't have
somebody telling that you release it out
in the world the group hears your song
and they sue you for a song maybe that
you've never heard before in your life
you've just stepped on a melodic land
mine
the thing is
this is the world before my colleague
noan rubai ruben and i have started our
project the world now looks like this
we've filled in every melody that's ever
existed and ever can exist
every step is going to be a melodic
landmine and ironically this is actually
trying to help songwriters let me tell
you how
i'm a lawyer i've been a lawyer since
2002 i've litigated copyright cases i've
taught law school copyright cases
i'm also a musician i have a bachelor's
degree in music i'm a performer i'm a
recording artist and i also produce
records and i'm also a technologist i've
been coding since 1985 for the web since
95. i've done cyber security and i also
currently design software so that puts
me right in the middle of a venn diagram
that gives me a few insights that if i
were in any one of those areas i might
not have had and my colleague noah
reuben in addition to being one of the
smartest people i've ever known he's
also a musician and he's also one of the
most brilliant programmers i've known
and between our work we came to a
realization that you may have had saying
you know that new song that sounds a lot
like this other old song and there's a
reason for that we've discovered that
there is only so many melodies there are
only so many notes that can be arranged
in so many ways and that's different
than say visual art where they're an
infinite number of brush strokes and an
infinite number of colors and an
infinite number of subjects that to
accidentally do them is very difficult
similarly with language the english
language has 117 000 words in it so the
odds of accidentally writing the same
paragraph are next to zero in contrast
music doesn't have 117 thousand words
music has eight notes
do remy faso latido one two three four
five six seven eight and every popular
melody that's ever existed and ever can
exist is those eight notes
now that's remarkably small and i worked
in cyber security and i know if i wanted
to attack your password and hack your
password one way to do it is to use a
computer to really quickly say aaa no
aab aac and to keep running until it
hits your password that's called brute
forcing a password so i thought you know
what if you could brute force melodies
what if you could say
and then exhaust every melody that's
ever been and the way the computers read
music is called midi and in midi it
looks like this
so i approached my colleague noah i said
noah can you write an algorithm to be
able to march through every melody
that's ever existed and ever can exist
he said yeah i could do that
so at a rate of 300 000 melodies per
second he wrote a program to write to
disc every melody that's ever existed
and ever can exist and in my hand right
now is every melody that's ever existed
and ever can exist and the thing is
to be copyrighted you don't have to do
anything formal as soon as it's written
to a fixed tangible medium this hard
drive it's copyrighted automatically
now this leaves copyright law with a
very interesting question because you
think about the world before
and songwriters had to avoid every song
that's ever been written in red no and i
have exhausted the entire melodic
copyright so if you superimpose the
songs that have been written and read
with the songs that haven't yet been
written you have an interesting question
have we infringed every melody that's
ever been
and in the future every songwriter
writes in the green spots have they
infringed us
now you might think at this point are
you some sort of copyright troll that's
trying to take over the world and i
would say no i am not absolutely not we
in fact the opposite is true noah and i
are songwriters ourselves we want to
make the world better for songwriters so
what we've done is we're taking
everything and putting it in the public
domain we're trying to keep space open
for songwriters to be able to make music
and we're not focused on lyrics we're
not focused on recordings we're focused
on melodies and the things we're running
out of melodies that we can use the
copyright system is broken and it needs
updating some of the insights that we
received as part of our work is that
melodies to a computer are just numbers
because
those melodies have existed since the
beginning of time and we're only just
discovering them so the melody doremi
raido to a computer is literally one two
three two one
so really the number one two three two
one is just a number it's just math
that's been existing since the beginning
of time and under the copyright laws
numbers are facts and under copyright
law facts either have thin copyright
almost no copyright or no copyright at
all
so maybe if these numbers have existed
since the beginning of time or we're
just plucking them out
maybe melodies are just math which is
just facts which maybe are not
copyrightable maybe if somebody is suing
over a melody alone not lyrics not
recordings but just the melody alone
maybe those cases go away maybe they get
dismissed now you might say well what
constitutes a melody and we were
initially going to take the entire piano
keyboard and be able to do the all the
entire keyboard but we thought you know
let's focus on the vocal range which is
actually two octaves and then we thought
no actually we're thinking about pop
music which is the only thing that makes
money that people sue over so we looked
at musicologists and musicologists have
debated what is a motif a short melody
versus a longer melody and so the number
we landed on was 12 12 notes and then we
superimposed that number with songs that
have either been litigated or threatened
to be litigated so for example the
chiffons had he's so fine oh so fine
versus
my sweet lord
oh sweet lord eight notes
that's so close
oh i
won't back down
no i
won't back down
versus
won't you stay with me
cause you're all i need
10 notes
[Music]
[Music]
last two notes of difference the jury
didn't care 2.8 million dollars
so every song within that is within our
parameters of eight notes up major and
minor 12 notes across
so what do you see in red is every
popular melody that's ever existed and
ever can exist so all no and i had to do
is to be able to exhaust that remarkably
finite remarkably small data set
there aren't that many of them eight up
12 across
so you might say damian songs are more
than just melodies there's chords too
and i would totally agree with you
because it turns out that that's even
easier in 2017 peter burke i'm sure
exhausted every chord you can download
it today in github we're instead focused
on
not on lyrics not on recordings we're
focused on melodies and the thing is
we're running out because the song isn't
just a single melody but there are many
parts to a song and each part of that
song can have many motifs and many
melodies within it so each song can have
up to 10 melodies and motifs so
soundcloud which is a way that musicians
can upload to this website and
distribute their work soundcloud
currently has 200 million songs and the
number of open spaces is shrinking
exponentially because every basement
musician is recording and they're
recording and they're uploading it to
youtube they're uploading it to spotify
they're uploading it to soundcloud and
they are exhausting the entire
mathematical data set they are
exhausting the open spaces until there's
not going to be any more left
what noah and i have done is we're
trying to preserve those spots that are
left we're trying to be able to take
those green spots put them in the public
domain so that other people can be able
to make them because we're running out
now the thing is we're just getting
started because if you go to our website
all the music dot info you can not only
download all the music we've made which
is a lot you can also download the
program that we used and we're giving
away the code for free so you can expand
upon our work something i didn't tell
you is that those eight notes that we
did as we speak right now we've expanded
that to 12 notes so instead of just the
white notes now we've got the black
notes too so we're covering jazz we're
covering classical music and we think
it's only a matter of time before
somebody's going to expand that to do
the entire piano keyboard and take our
12 notes and expand it to 100 with every
rhythmic variation and every chordal
variation until our remarkably finite
mathematical data set gets further
exhausted
this is going to happen and the thing is
how is the law going to respond because
the thing is we're not focused on
somebody copying a previous person's
melody we're focused instead of somebody
accidentally copying a song that they
either have heard and forgotten about or
have never heard before in their lives
and the chance of landing in an open
spot is remarkably small and it's
shrinking every day and the thing is the
odds of you as a songwriter getting sued
are remarkably high and if you get sued
you're going to want to think about what
a judge or a jury is going to think
about and the judge or jury is going to
think about two questions the first
question a judge of jury is going to
think about is is that previous
songwriters copyright valid do they even
have a copyright in that previous song
second question is did you infringe
their copyright so to the first question
maybe the answer to that is no because
if they're suing just over the melody
maybe that melody has existed since the
beginning of time
maybe there are only so many notes that
are math that are not copyrightable to
that second question did you infringe
there are two sub questions the first
question is did you access did you hear
that previous song
and if so are those two songs
substantially similar now the first
question did you access or hear that
previous song that's got a lot of
problems it's really problematic and the
reason for that is there are only a few
cases where access is crystal clear for
example john fogerty was alleged to have
infringed john fogerty when he was part
of credence so clearly john fogerty had
access to john fogerty's songs okay on
the opposite end of the spectrum on nova
access what if a baby were to sing into
their toy and again as soon as the toy
recorder happens it's copyrighted
automatically it's a fixed tangible
medium so if a baby starts singing
and a year later taylor swift sings i
stay up too late get nothing in my brain
clearly taylor swift has not infringed
that baby because taylor swift has not
heard that baby's recording okay clear
case of no access
but the thing is almost none of the
cases are that clear what if there's a
question mark as to whether the second
person heard it or not maybe they heard
it maybe they didn't maybe they heard it
and forgot it maybe they subconsciously
infringed these are all what the law
calls fact questions and the thing is
almost every copyright case that comes
out is a fact question almost never is
it as clear as john fogerty or as clear
as taylor swift almost every case is
that middle section that fact question
and the hard part about fact questions
is they're notoriously hard to resolve
at an early stage in the case because
when you think about a lifespan of a
lawsuit starts out as cease and desist
letter you need to pay me or i'll sue
you it goes forward and it's going to
take years and the thing about fact
questions they don't get resolved until
the end of that process that's what
happened to george harrison after trial
the judge said i think you
subconsciously infringed so if you're a
songwriter who has never heard a melody
before but you are approached by
somebody saying hey i think you stole my
song what are you gonna do
sam smith was approached by tom petty
tom petty said my song won't back down
sounds like your stay with me sam smith
reportedly responded hey man i've never
heard your song before that was written
before i was born but i if i was in sam
smith position i would look at this long
row ahead of me and then the prospect at
the end of a judge saying you know i
think he's subliminally infringed so
what are you going to do
it's not surprising that sam smith made
tom petty a co-songwriter giving tom
petty a lot of his songwriting royalties
radiohead had a song and i'm a creep i'm
a weirdo the holly said hey that sounds
like our song they made them
co-songwriters lana del rey ironically
had a song that sounds like creep
offered to make them co-songwriters
reportedly katy perry had a song that
she
testified and all of her co-songwriters
testified i have never heard that
previous song before in my life and the
other side didn't dispute it they say
you know we have no evidence that they
actually heard the song but we did have
three point some million youtube views
so they must have heard it a jury agreed
with them and katy perry was on the hook
for 2.8 million dollars now if you are
an accused songwriter who's never heard
the song before that is an untenable
position how are you going to avoid
getting shaken down for something that
you may have never heard shouldn't there
be an easier way shouldn't there be a
way that early on in that process for a
judge or a lawyer to be able to have an
early evidentiary hearing to say maybe
melodies are math which are facts which
are not copyrightable or maybe there's
no evidence showing that this later
person has heard the earlier person song
maybe the idea of subconscious
infringement goes away
now if you are a songwriter you should
really care about this because each day
you are walking in a minefield that you
didn't even know was there you're trying
to avoid every song whether you've heard
that song or not
and noah and i we're trying to preserve
those open spaces so that you can be
able to make the music in the public
domain in a way that you've always
thought the question is not have i made
this new song or not because no song is
new no and i have exhausted the data set
the real question is my song a green
song or is my song a red song or perhaps
the real question is should you have the
blank page that everybody thinks is
there in the first place if you're a
judge or a lawyer think about having an
early evidentiary hearing to be able to
take the evidentiary burden from the
defendant to prove negative that they've
never heard that song and bring it back
to the plaintiff where it belongs that
they have to prove that the other side
heard the song and they have to prove
that that melody is more than just a
fact
and if you are a song lover you should
really care about this because the
current state is a chilling effect on
songwriters something that i haven't
told you is that george harrison after
the trial he stopped writing music for a
while he told rolling stone that you
know after the trial it's hard to start
writing again because every song i hear
sounds like something else there's a
reason for that george
because there are only so many notes
there are only so many melodies
and the open spaces are running out
exponentially
now ironically noah and i have made all
the melodies and put them into the
public domain in an effort to try to
give songwriters more freedom to be able
to make more and more music and less
fear of accidentally stepping on musical
landmines noah and i have made all the
music
to be able to allow future songwriters
to make all
of their
music
thank you